what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay the Inhumans are dead thank God
like there's no one out there who's like
oh no the Inhumans are dead oh it's so
sad no it's not everybody hates the
Inhumans like a poor man's x-men okay
so death of the Inhumans Donnie Cates
strikes again - this guy Jesus Christ
this guy this guy can write a comic book
about about like the x-men staring it
like a blank wall and he'd be like the
most exciting thing I was like this is
the best story ever the only is amazing
Donnie Cates is one hell of a writer so
this whole thing kicks off literally
with like the Inhumans observing all
these Inhumans out in space who have
basically been killed and they have the
words join or die written on their chest
and of course you've got Black Bolt
basically taking down all their names
different things like that but there is
a reason why this happened now something
else that I also want to explain here
I'm gonna talk about here for a second
if something called the four cities now
when it comes to the Inhumans there's
technically five cities there is the
main and main Attilan city of the
Inhumans which is the ones you used to
see Medusa Black Bolt so on and so forth
during Jonathan Hickman's run on the
Fantastic fork he introduced something
that least a concept called the war of
the four cities and what you ended up
learning was that in the early days of
in human society there were those who
broke away and formed their other tribes
formed for other tribes and the idea was
that in order to maintain peace among
the tribes
blackbolt basically married brides from
each one of the tribes so he had his
main wife Medusa and then he had his
side chicks and in doing this what he
did is it it created a kind of peace of
sorts but that's what Marvel used is
kind of a jumping out like kind of a
launching platform when you went into
like the aftermath of infinity when you
ended up having like the Terrigen bomb
that was that was detonated by Black
Bolt and then in turn the Terrigen mist
spread throughout the rest of the world
it was it was kind of like building on
that that principle of that hickman
established which allowed him to in turn
set off the events of infinity which in
turn allowed Marvel to set off the
events of of in human but the fact
remains the idea was to basically meet
with the other inhuman tribes to
essentially sit down and to say here's
what we're gonna do either we're gonna
surrender to the Kree who were basically
going on this rampage and killing
everybody or we're going to go we're
gonna vote for war the idea of Black
Bolt was to vote for war but getting
here and basically realized and they're
like all these members had been killed
and they've all basically been executed
safe for one which is basically dying
that Gordon goes through reads their
mind and that's when he finds out that
essentially what had happened was that
when this meeting was initially set up
that essentially a person named Vox like
a being named Vox who was essentially
working for the creek showed up here now
Vox if you
notice box looks almost exactly like
Black Bolt from the earth x-series I
don't really know if there's a reason
for that but probably because that
version of Black Bolt looks really
badass Vox shows up here and it's
basically like look you have an option
you can either join or you can die and
the response was all these these leaders
these these Queens of these tribes voted
to join and in response Vox was like
you're gonna die and the reason why was
because the message Vox was sending who
was not intended to to sit in message to
all the inhuman tribes around the around
the universe and said like hey you know
join us or die it was a message meant
for Black Bolt there's a we'll find out
why here in a minute and so the message
is I'm wiping out everything you know
and love and not only that really the
stance of Vox
is the the Kree Empire has no room for
cowards and if you're willing to
surrender
you're a coward and we're basically
getting rid of you and so literally like
all of them are essentially just like
wiped out and they're annihilated only
for Gorgon to realize there's a bomb
attached to her chest which is one of
the reasons why she wasn't immediately
killed because Vox knew the Inhumans
would run to her side and try to get
what information they could or try to
save her life hopefully bring her aboard
the ship and then you know everything
blows up and they all end up getting
kill in the process and so basically
everybody except for Gorgon is
teleported out of there by lockjaw and
that's when when they really begin to
realize what all's going on here that if
the crusade is to wipe out the Inhumans
and a bulk of the Inhumans have already
been annihilated but when they all
basically met in one seeder location
that only really leaves one location
left that's the home of the Inhumans on
the planet Earth on the blue area of the
moon and so that's what it's kind of
like okay look we have to get back as
soon as we can only for us to find out
there Vox has been going through there
and killing every single inhuman on the
moon executing them all I mean no
quarters given no questions asked
he's just going through not saying a
word just annihilating them all just
just obliterating every last one of them
until he comes across Maximus the man
now actually was the man of course the
crazy brother of Black Bolt he's kind of
like the the load like the inhuman
version of Loki and literally pulls out
like this this freaking like the biggest
gun I've ever seen
and just like opens fire on Vox and
that's that like Black Bolt begins to
sort of put the pieces together and say
look we have to jump back and get there
as fast as possible well the problem
with this is that the rendezvous point
this meeting ground was designed to be
in a location where people couldn't just
jump to right because that's how
ambushes get set up and so they
literally have to like race back to a
point where they can teleport where
lockjaw
can teleport to a location and arrives
on the scene and the response of Vox is
I want you
to send a message well of course Maximus
is else'd a message like I'm not a
messenger
like I'm not a message boy and so Vox is
response is fine if you won't send it
willingly then you'll send it with your
death and kills them both
just like annihilates them both in the
spot and it's just like Jesus I mean
it's just it's it's it's it's insane I
mean it's just just killing them left
and right just annihilating them at
every single chance that he gets and so
this goes into really like the bigger
picture of what's going on here about
like why all these Inhumans are being
killed and so what is up happening is
Carnac who is a member of the inhuman
world family he doesn't actually have
powers he just can sense the weakness
and things and basically he goes to the
Kree Empire and what's left of it and
this is an important thing because over
the course of the last really like if we
brought up until about secret wars wrote
roughly around the time the secret wars
happened theory Empire Marvel II kind of
been riding it in a state of decline and
so what we end up finding out here was
that somewhere along the line there was
the supreme intelligence kind of the
religious leader of the Kree Empire had
sent a faction of the Kree a race into
the farthest reaches of space to explore
the edge of the universe to see what was
there to see what was available during
that time while they were exploring the
events of annihilation the events of
annihilation conquests the events of a
black vortex had gone on so that when
these guys came back what they basically
found was that the Kree race had been
pushed to the brink of extinction and
their stance was you're all cowards
you're all cowards and failures of men
if you guys were so easily easily
destroyed if you were so easily defeated
then you're all useless you have no real
place here and so in response to this
the supreme intelligence was eliminated
Ron in the accuser and the other accuser
course were exiled and these old creeks
are kind of retaking the throne and
setting things back to the way they used
to be we're gonna take it back to the
day when the Kree race was a race of
power and the first step to doing that
is eliminating all the old things so
that's why they're going through and
killing all the Inhumans is because in
their in their mind the Inhumans are a
basically reminiscent of like the new
way of priests do anything they're the
reminiscent of the Kree weakness and so
you end up having like you know of
course carnet basically saying look like
I'm not here to surrender to you that
was never gonna happen like I'm here to
talk about surrender but I'm here to
talk about your surrender and that's
when you end up having him basically
saying like my king blackballed has a
message and when Carnot's taken hostage
when he's stabbed
blackbolt walks into this place and just
starts screaming and it's one of the
coolest thing is it's one of the coolest
things ever where black ball goes
through and just starts screaming and
killing everyone he sees just just
screaming at all these in the ali's all
these creeks and just destroy
their physical form just like I'm not
just annihilating and as he goes through
and as he says this that in years
following that people would begin to
call it the black eulogy that that black
boat was going through and what he was
doing was saying the names of all the
Inhumans who had been killed by the Kree
up to that point and just literally
delivering this eulogy that resulted in
the deaths of all these different
priests soldiers I mean and they flew in
everything they brought in like warships
they brought in tanks labor I mean that
like there was day they brought in at
all and he doesn't he destroyed them all
nonetheless so here talk about a guy
whose voice is powerful enough to
destroy planets so it kind of makes
sense but as he's doing this he's
literally tearing apart his vocal cords
and so what is happening is that in the
midst of all this Vox takes Karnak and
is basically like you can stop screaming
or carnet can die and so Black Bolt
which is like this is actually a change
of play a change of pace blackbolt ends
up using like like inhuman sign language
now historically speaking that's not
what blackballed ever did whenever black
what would communicate Medusa would
always go with him and the reason why
was because she was the one that could
basically read his body language and
know what it is that he's wanting to say
you know it was like she's just knew him
that well and so that's that's the kind
of interesting thing because it allows
Donnie Cates to bring in the idea of
Black Bolt operating independently of
everybody else without medusa being
there but still being able to
communicate to a degree and so when when
he literally starts moving in sign and
the question of ox is what the heck is
he saying
Carnot's response is black bolts saying
don't kill him take me instead
and that's exactly what vox does Vox
moves behind black bolt and slices his
throat taking away his ability to scream
it's pretty brutal and so from there
like literally they reach stitches his
throat back together but that was the
nature of the prophecy the prophecy here
was that the Kree created the Inhumans
and the entire human project was
scrapped through it was supposed to be
scrapped because a prophecy came into
existence is said somewhere along the
line one of these inhuman projects is
going to destroy the Kree Empire and so
basically that that prophecy comes in
the form of Black Bolt
hence the reason why his throat was
slashed because if he can't scream he
can't destroy the Empire and so the idea
is to keep basically heated in prison
but also force him to witness the death
of everything he loves and were a couple
of the guys begin it on him he suddenly
kind of just starts whispering names and
this is what it sort of gives birth to a
new power with Black Bolt in the sense
that instead of having this quasi sonic
scream that destroys everything around
it it kind of emits like this
high-pitched pulse and as it does that
it just kind of scrambles the brains of
the people around him kind of creates
somewhat of a vibrating effect I would
imagine and it basically results in the
death of these two soldiers and so with
him doing that he starts walking through
wisp
in the ears of these guys and it's
destroying their brains in the process
picks up one of the guns and goes on a
rampage starts killing everyone he can
find him and once he gets into the
actual science room he finds Ron in the
accuser and it's a sad moment because
what we end up finding out here is that
Ron in the accuser end of himself is
pretty powerful but the idea was to
basically subjugate him to turn him into
some kind of a hybrid so we don't really
know what the exact intention was and so
what did what he tells him what Ronon
tells blackbolt is do not leave me like
this I am a warrior of Honor I'm a man
who's fought who's lived
and-and-and-and fought an honorable life
do not let me die a death like this give
me an honorable death and that's the
response of blackbolt he literally
Westerners in his ears says you are
forgiven for everything you've done and
that kills Ron in the accuser it's sad
like it's a very sad thing because you
have this battle-hardened guy who's just
kind of living out his last days hooked
up to a machine being converted into
some kind of cyborg organism and so what
you end up having is the rest of the
Inhumans you have Medusa you have
crystal the other se and humans who sit
down and say we can't save Black Bolt on
our own we need help and so what they
end up doing is travelling off to like
the far reaches out in the middle of
nowhere you know under we're really to
Marcus and Tory and when they get there
they say this is the person we're
hunting for only for us to find out
there looking for beta ray bill
something else to notice here is beta
ray bill has a dad bod because he's just
been getting drunk that's all he's been
doing not only that initially he brushes
them off right he's just kinda like I
don't care and there's no reason for him
to but what we end up finding out here
is that beta ray bill and lockjaw were
actually really good friends apparently
they had adventures together like beta
ray bill and lockjaw had like adventures
together like they went and like did
stuff and had like these amazing moments
and stories Oh buddy I want to read that
like I want to read like a miniseries
like we're at lunch is a series of one
shot where it's just like like the
adventures of beta ray bill and lockjaw
like I think I think it'd be absolutely
amazing to see me hey ray bill and
lockjaw teaming up and going on
adventures together but the fact remains
once they sit down and basically explain
to beta ray bill what's going on his
stance is okay fine you guys just sit
tight I'll take care of it Andy and his
response is absolutely not because this
is this is our races aren't like we're
we're here for your help but we're not
here to have you do all the heavy
lifting and that makes sense because
remember historically speaking when it
comes to the Inhumans they usually keep
their stuff in-house they don't usually
air their dirty laundry right there much
like the x-men in that regard what
happens in in human society stays in in
human society and so with Black Bolt
going through and basically like
whispering the ears of these soldiers
killing all these different guys he ends
up coming face to face with Vox and as
he
and as he fights them this also leads to
the arrival of like beta ray bill and so
of course beta ray bill throws his
hammer in some incapacitating box and
basically you know kind of knocking some
sense into him and the reason why is
because once that happens vox begins to
kind of look around and say where the
hell am i what's going on here right now
and so the initial response is to try to
kill him and while medusa you know
reconciles with blackpot where they get
back together again uh you end up having
like like carnac who literally goes
through and starts tearing apart the
armor of vox like literally just sorts
like ripping all this stuff apart only
for us to find out that this vox is
actually Maximus the mad there's kind of
a crazy thing in the middle of all that
the bomb goes off inside this version of
Vox which which incinerates crystal
inner entirety so now she's dead
but once this is realized that is
actually Maximus than that the question
becomes why in the world would not to
miss the mad turn against the Inhumans
and that's when we end up following
crystal and we end up basically
realizing that what's happening here is
is lockjaw Maximus the mad crystal
they're not being killed they're being
teleported they're being sent to the
labs of the Kree and what they're doing
is they're experimenting like they're
literally modifying the genes of of all
the Inhumans they capture and they're
turning them all into Vox that Vox is
not one person Vox is an army of people
now how many inhuman here Inhumans here
that they have we don't know we just it
seems like they have hundreds if not
possibly even thousands as those kind of
bonkers to see all that because this
Karnak who begins to pick it up karna
begins to realize what's going on in
basically says if all these are versions
of a character named Vox that means
there has to be a Vox Prime and if
there's a Vox prime that is entirely
possible there's a hive mind there kind
of network and if there is sever the
source and you free everybody else but
the other response of Karnak is one
thing you have to remember Black Bolt is
you have one good scream left in your
voice after that your voice will be gone
forever you'll never be able to scream
you'll never be able to talk again and
so we're black bolts initial response is
to believe that Karnak wants him to
basically play it safe to kind of say
like stay behind play your role as king
and instead what Karnak says is like I'm
not telling you not to scream what I'm
telling you is that when the time comes
when you do scream make it count
make sure it's a scream that will level
that people will talk about from now
until eons to come and so that's when
the Inhumans basically launched their
attack they they literally like end up
tagging like the home base of the Kree
Empire at least what's left of the Kree
Empire they literally fly their ship
into the Citadel only to turn around and
be met by crystal who's been transformed
into Vox and lockjaw who's been
transformed as well that was kind of a
cool thing because well this
is lock John's alive so it means I can
save lockjaw which is awesome because as
we all know we don't care what happens
in the movie TV show and/or comic so
long as you don't hurt the dogs do not
hurt the dog because if you hurt the dog
there will be hell to pay but
nonetheless facing I think it's like all
these Vox characters that's the other
thing that Carnac picked up on is
originally what they believed was that
Vox had like all the inhuman powers but
what they're doing is that because all
these versions of Vox are in humans with
their powers still intact
they're basically fighting an army of
Inhumans with a wide array of different
abilities teleportation and all those
different things and so for the most
part they're all basically lost and so
Black Bolt does the only thing that he
believes he can do because of the fact
these guys are all lost they've been
totally transformed there's no way to
seemingly recover them or at least
there's an appear to be a way to recover
them what Black Bolt ends up doing is
screaming and basically destroys all
these Inhumans who are Vox hosts who are
who are essentially foxes and this is
rough because when you're Black Bolt
when you're the midnight king of the
Inhumans society your stance is I have
to protect my people I have to keep my
people safe this is like Charles Xavier
if he had to kill all the x-men it's
crushing like it's a devastating thing
for him to have to do but in reality
it's the better option here because they
don't have the time to basically go back
and like fix all this and so they do the
only thing they can do in the middle of
all this what it does is it destroys a
kind of neural hub basically of the Vox
concepts what comes out of this is a
basically freeze lockjaw and it frees it
frees crystal but they're the only the
only one to the Inhumans outside of like
the immediate royal family who are
basically left alive and so what this
means is that all Inhumans across the
world when they basically kind of
remaster their forces all the Inhumans
who have ever existed in the universe
who currently do exist in the universe
are all dead the only Inhumans that
currently exist are Black Bolt Medusa
Gorgon Kraken and crystal and lockjaw
and that's it everybody else is gone
it's it's kind of nuts is basically
resetting it all back to zero it's very
House of em wiping out all the Inhumans
across the universe and reducing the
number down to only like five or six and
that's it but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you